[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Rosa Pérez mateu ya con
nosotros en el estudio Rosa miércoles ya
a mitad de esta semana y vamos a dedicar
la revista de prensa del día de hoy a la
Diosa de la prensa internacional a
mijaíl gorbachov el último líder del
Unión soviética empezamos por algunos
medios de nuestro continente rosa así es
Y antes de entrar al análisis en
particular de los distintos medios
señalar que hay líneas que se repiten en
los periódicos alrededor del mundo no
que es señalar precisamente como sus dos
reformas a farola perestroika y el glass
nos impactaron y acabaron desencadenando
finalmente el colapso de la unión
soviética y también es su política
exterior que puso fin a la guerra fría y
por otro lado también estos dos puntos
no que por un lado es muy alabado por
occidente y ahora le vamos a ver con la
prensa occidental Pero por otro lado no
están celebrado en el interior de Rusia
tratado como traidor efectivamente Vamos
a entrar en esto cuando analicemos los
medios rusos empezamos por el New York
Times que dice mijaíl gorbachov
1931-2022 el líder soviético visionario
que levantó el pelo el telón de acero
que aquí también llaman a cortina de
hierro no hay distintas traducciones o
Estado de Sao Paulo de Brasil dice el
último líder de la unión soviética muere
a los 91 años y por otro lado también
este periódico asegura que gorbachov es
la antítesis de Vladimir Putin dicen
gorbachov no deseaba ni preveía el fin
de la URSS pero él no colocaba sus
deseos por encima de la realidad Clarín
de Argentina dice el líder que cambió el
mapa del mundo un gran luchador por la
paz recordemos que por eso le otorgaron
el premio Nobel en el 1990 o la tercera
de chile le atribuye el fin de la Guerra
Fría vamos ahora a Europa donde derribó
la cortina de hierro rosa así es
Frankfurt
necesita presentarlo digamos este medio
alemán dice directamente muere mijael
gorbachov the Times el medio británico
los cita respecto a una frase que
pronunció en 1992 diciendo me veo a mí
mismo como un hombre que empezó la
reformas necesarias para el país para
Europa y para el mundo y también señala
eso no el contraste que decíamos muy
odiado en su país Esta es la palabra
heidith que utiliza the Times pero
celebrado en occidente no y por qué
odiado en su país por la caída de los
estándares debida la caída de la
economía tras el colapso de la urs y
también la pérdida de consideración de
la superpotencia que representaba la
unión soviética y también de nuevo la
comparación con Putin dice se considera
que Putin quiere erradicar las
libertades que gorbachov introdujo lomo
dice el hombre del fin de la unión
soviética y dice simbólicamente
desaparece en el momento que en Moscú se
impone su antítesis de nuevo no del
acercamiento presidente a la nueva
confrontación frontal que supone Putin y
corriere de la cera adiós a corbachov
quien cambió el mundo no tenía muy buena
relación Vladimir Putin y gorbachov rosa
incluso Es evidente que él sí estaba de
acuerdo con la postura de anexar crimea
a territorio ruso a Rusia pero si no
estaba de acuerdo con la guerra en
Ucrania Pues todo eso también lo vamos a
analizar con nuestro primer invitado del
día pero vamos a ver ahora el mosquitán
este medio ruso de carácter occidental
basado en Países Bajos desde que
precisamente comenzó esta guerra
efectivamente él dice su era la de
gorbachov empezó en 1985 con la reforma
del sistema soviético conocida como
perestroika recordemos un nombre ruso
que significaría reestructuración
reconstrucción y que se popularizó
accidente sin traducción dice y terminó
con el golpe de estado fallido
recordemos que llevó al colapso de la
unión soviética en
1991 dice también el mosquito Times
aseguró como decíamos que nunca fue su
objetivo pero su objetivo su digamos
proyecto empezó una reacción en cadena
que cambió el mundo también señala que
sus abuelos pasaron por gulags y que eso
influyó en su visión del estalinismo
también dice que quizás fue chernóbil y
no la perestroika lo que llevó al
colapso de la urs esto lo comentó el
mismo gorbachov vamos con la agencia
tasa quien dio la noticia no y continúa
con información con la portada
exactamente esta agencia rusa que
todavía lleva en portada digamos la
información con la que reportó la muerte
del ex líder soviético y señalamos esta
frase no esta noche tras una serie y
prolongada enfermedad
mijaelvich corbachov ha muerto bueno
Rosa vamos con sputnik este medio tan
afín a la línea del kremlin No sí
básicamente señala lo que bien
comentabas que algunos lo veían como un
idealista otros como un reformista y
otros como un traidor e incluso a gente
de la Cia Rosa y pasamos ahora a dos o
de los medios rusos de referencia vamos
a ver cuáles estos medios por un lado el
comersante defiende su legado dice que
las reformas que impulsó al final eran
necesarias en el contexto en el que se
encontraba la unión soviética y por otro
lado bedomustic señala algunas de las
frases digamos que han quedado para la
historia de gordas
precisamente como comentaba su relación
quizás no era la más armoniosa pero él
decía que Putin heredó el caos y que
impulsó algunas medidas extraordinarias
de carácter autoritario pero que eran
comprensibles Hasta cierto límite vamos
ahora a ver cómo lo titula el global
Times este medio chino precisamente dice
que a pesar de ser muy alabado por
occidente recordemos que el global Times
es un medio vinculado con el partido
comunista chino y de carácter Ultra
nacionalista dice que según observadores
chinos
legado de gorbachov tiene que ser una
advertencia a otros países no menciona
china pero se entiende para que sean
cautelosos ante cualquier intento de
evolución pacífica por parte de las
fuerzas occidentales y no la voy a decir
rosa sin antes ver un icónico vídeo
efectivamente que lo destaca el sauchina
morning post para quedarnos en China y
es un anuncio comercial para la
televisión de
1997 que protagonizó precisamente
gorbachov supuestamente para recaudar
dinero para su fundación pero al mismo
tiempo promoviendo la cadena de
pizzerías estadounidense Pizza Hut no y
al mismo tiempo enalteciendo así su
legado porque recordemos permitió la
inversión extranjera en Rusia y
precisamente en este anuncio vemos una
familia que discute sobre el polémico
legado de gorbachov pero finalmente la
abuela de la familia alcanza el consenso
recordando que gracias a él tienen Pizza
Hut en el país veíamos un fragmento
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y paradójicamente estas grandes cadenas
como también marcas occidentales y
Estados Unidos se fueron de Rusia causa
de la guerra Gracias Rosa como siempre
por toda la información mañana con más
revista de prensa seguimos analizando el
tema de corbachov con este primer
invitado al día